what are you doing in miami well what's
everybody doing in miami uh well other
people are living here yeah
yeah all right that's why have you seen
have you bought any art yet no i said no
one will take my gold bars for the heart
i'm lugging them around they're getting
heavy
no i'm here i want to buy some nfts
really
of course not
do you really not this is some bitcoin
art i brought it with me yeah yeah it's
right it's right here in fact i put it
it's all over the table
you can't see it you can't touch it it
has no actual value no real utility do
you really sell it to you i have a
serious question
do you own any bitcoin for real no well
i own some i just can't get at it why
well i guess i don't have my password
you said you realize that sounds really
good but i don't know yes but i don't
even have a full bitcoin there it's only
like a third of a bitcoin okay so a good
thing you didn't send me 100. so it's 20
000. so it's 20 000 for the bitcoin yeah
but you know that's the wallet you were
supposed to send me a hundred dollars
worth of bitcoin to you never did which
is just as well because you know it's
lost okay what what would it take to get
you to buy some bitcoin
well why would i buy bitcoin though no
you didn't answer the question what
would it take to get you to buy some
bitcoin
well i i guess how far would gold
gave me some money under the with the
condition that i had to use it to buy
bitcoin i guess i'd have to buy bitcoin
because i'm an honorable person so if it
was your money i guess i would buy it i
don't want to buy with my own money if
and when bitcoin passes gold's market
capital you buy some
well
a i don't think it's ever gonna pass
gold's market cap but you know that's a
good
starting point for a conversation
because everybody always wants to look
at the market cap of gold and just
assume that bitcoin is going to take
that market cap but
you know a good chunk of that market cap
probably half of it has to do with
gold's use and jewelry no right wrong
wrong yes it is seven percent no it's
not you want to bank it out you want a
bet what percent what percent of goals
market cap is held by investors
my guess my guess is uh a pretty big
percentage now it's about 20
you know so bitcoin already almost has
that market cap right because it can't
replace gold in industry it can't
replace gold in jewelry gold gold market
cap is about 13 trillion okay so
according to this hold on according to
this distribution of gold demand
worldwide bisector in 2020 this is uh
i'm talking about the actual hold on it
says jewelry is 36 percent investment is
46 cents
and technology is eight percent yeah but
i can talk about that but the market cap
includes all the gold that's above
ground okay right that includes you know
the gold in everybody's jewelry
there's a lot of gold that's it that's
held in jewelry that's a good chunk of
the market cap so bitcoin can't take
that market cap you you you can't make
any jewelry out of bitcoin i mean i
think that bitcoin's market cap is
already close to gold's when it comes to
individual
private ownership for investment
purposes i'm not counting central banks
so how much how much do you think is
investment demand for gold
50 i know i think about 20
of the the above ground gold that's
right part of the market like two
trillion yeah two two yeah two two and a
half trillion and that's kind of close
to the market cap for bitcoin already
well that would be bitcoin would have to
double to get there no no
but if you take it points out bitcoins
at one trillion dollars right all right
but if you take all the cryptos yeah
ether and all the rest of the crap but
those aren't trying to compete well well
sure they are with gold no with bitcoin
they think they're not they're trying to
do other things no they're not yeah
they're competing with bitcoin for
people who want to gamble on crypto
tokens do you think that most people are
buying bitcoin because they're trying to
gamble of course they're buying bitcoin
because they think it's going to a
hundred thousand or they think it's
going to a million that's why they're
buying it but how much of your portfolio
is in stocks like fifty percent
my portfolio well my stock portfolio is
all stocks
but like your financial portfolio what
percentage is like just all equities in
general
well i mean if you exclude real estate
that i owe yeah yeah and private
businesses yeah you look at like how my
you know like liquid portfolio yeah i'm
mostly in stocks okay vast majority of
what i have and so when you buy them in
stocks when you buy it uh equity you're
buying it because you think that it's
going to go up in value against the
dollar
no
mostly i'm buying companies that i think
are undervalued they pay good dividends
to me
i want to get out of paper i don't want
to own
bonds because i think
bonds are going to lose value you sold
them all well i didn't really sell my
bonds because i never really owned any i
mean i had i had some
uh foreign bonds uh but i'm almost all
in
non-us equities and a lot of those
equities
are
mining companies and those are the that
part of my portfolio has not been
performing well um gold stocks have
really gotten hit
all right i want to give i want to give
you some softballs i'm going to let you
yeah do what you do best ready first
softball they say inflation 6.2 they've
been saying that it's transitory we now
have the retirement of the word
transitory like literally they should
have held an award ceremony put it in
the hall of fame it's retired yeah what
do you think about them not wanting to
use the word transitory anymore does
that mean that it's permanent or does
that mean that they just don't want to
talk about it anymore well i think
they're tired of trying to obfuscate as
to what they meant i mean i think
initially
when they said transitory they meant
transitory but then when it turned out
not to be transitory they had to kind of
redefine the word
and kind of you know to try to save face
but at this point they've they've
twisted it into such a pretzel that i
think they just want to walk away from
it because they really looked ridiculous
in the face of overwhelming evidence
that inflation was not transitory uh to
try to claim that it was
but i still think the methodology that
we're using today to calculate inflation
is deeply flawed and when they contrast
what's happening today to the 1970s
they never talk about the fact that the
cpi that exists today
is nothing like the one that existed
back in the night and this is cost of
living versus cost of uh goods yes i
mean basically now it's the cost of
surviving i mean by by today's
methodology look it doesn't matter if
you're eating philly mignon or dog food
as long as you're eating uh then you got
nothing to complain about right they
they don't really look at the quality
even though they claim to uh when they
have substitution or hedonics but that's
a savage car the whole thing is rigged
now but if if we were measuring prices
today
and we just used the same cpi that they
used back then
i think the inflation in 2021 was as bad
if not worse than any single year of the
1970s
and so what percentage would that be i
don't know probably thirteen fourteen
fifteen percent probably fifteen but
over ten yeah i mean if you look at
import export prices
those numbers are more real and that's
about what you see because they're
they're actually taking a look at how
much are the goods that we're importing
costing what are the goods that we're
exporting it's just apples to apples and
you can actually see the price prices
although anecdotally
most of the price increases that people
you know point out to me i get a lot of
emails and people show me hey this is
what i just bought and hear the exact
same thing i bought last year or six
months ago and you look at the price
increases uh they're much bigger than
six percent okay
second thing is that we now have jerome
powell as the fed reserve chairman going
to be renominated and continue good
decision bad decision or would you have
done something different if you were
president schiff
well there probably would be no fed if i
was
i would have already gotten rid of it
but um
look i predicted
on my podcast that biden would take the
coward's way out and re-nominate a pal i
mean why is it howard's way out well you
know you don't want to go out on the
limb
and put somebody else in there who's
your person because then if anything
goes wrong it's your fault right
you just leave the guy there that's
there because hey everybody wants them
there um and then if every something
goes wrong hey it's not my fault look
he's not my guy trump appointed him and
you know the republicans wanted me to
keep him and
uh so it's it's easier for him than
going out on a limb because if
if the economy does well or powell does
a good job then he gets credit for
reappointing him uh but to go out in
left field and and go for a brainerd or
somebody else and then something goes
wrong
you know why i mean trump kind of had to
get rid of yellen because he spent his
whole campaign bashing yellen uh
basically for doing exactly what he then
bashed powell for not doing until powell
got his mind right and started doing
exactly what trump criticized yellen for
doing
um
but look he's done a lousy job i mean if
you want to look at the fed's uh
you know
mandate of price stability we clearly
don't have it
um
but you know
i i think really what the fed's job is
as far as biden is concerned is helping
me get reelected and kicking the can
down the road until the next election do
you think anyone would do something
different like what would you have done
if you were in that seat
well you know what i would do
you know i would
let the markets know that the fed is no
longer going to be setting interest
rates that the market was going to do
that and we were going to start
liquidating our holdings of u.s treasury
because they should
and of course
in so doing there would be massive
losses uh that and you know
the bill goes to the u.s taxpayer you
know as the fed unwinds its balance
sheet any losses are i o used to the u.s
taxpayer because the us government has
to make the fed whole
um for that
um i also you know let the government
know that the fed is no longer in the
business of monetizing government debt
and that if you want your bill back
better you better figure out how you're
going to pay for it how okay this is
what i want to talk about as well is uh
they say it's cost zero dollars is that
[ __ ] of course is [ __ ] i mean
they always say that because their
assumptions are ludicrous like break it
down for me well the revenue assumptions
they're not going to get the revenue a
lot of the revenue is supposedly going
to come from extra irs agents you know
getting the rich to pay their fair share
well you know they're not going to get
much more money out of the rich uh
there's not that many rich people other
than you crypto guys
um but and you don't pay taxes anyway
because you never sell you're so salty
you're so salty you guys never sell so
they're not getting anything you'd be
one of the richest people in the world
if you bought bitcoin you first heard
about it keep going but um but they're
not going to get the revenue i mean
they're obviously mainly going to target
the middle class that's where the extra
irs enforcement is going but it's hard
to get blood from a stone so i don't
think they're going to get a lot of
revenue meanwhile
all these new programs are going to cost
so much more than they think i mean
first of all they act as if the programs
are going to go away in you know five
years
because they don't want to count the
spending in the out years although we
all know that these programs never go
away once they're there they're there
forever i mean we're still dealing with
temporary programs from the second world
war you know the war ended well why are
these temporary programs still in effect
right they never go away there's an old
saying it was milton friedman there's
nothing as permanent as a temporary
government program so to pretend that
these programs are going to sunset
is nonsense but also they have grossly
underestimated the cost
because the government doesn't
understand moral hazard they don't
understand what happens so
part of the buildback better
is everybody gets free
um uh preschool well
the cost of preschool is going to go way
up once the government makes it free
because now the demand for preschool
goes way up and now the spree schools
start jacking up their tuition because
they know the defense industry the
defender says oh you're gonna pay us all
this money we're gonna keep increasing
the cost of it to you because we got a
ton of money it's just like look what
government did to college tuition before
the government started subsidizing
college tuition and guaranteeing loans
college tuition was cheap government
gets involved and it costs a fortune so
it's gonna it's they're gonna end up
spending a lot more
on preschool than they think but i think
the biggest one is gonna be if it stays
in there because the senate might get
rid of it but that is the paid
family
medical leave
because everyone's going to take that
they just assume that well only the
people that actually have a medical
emergency
are going to ask for their four-week
paid vacation
no i mean didn't they learn their lesson
from the ppp or the extended
unemployment benefits if you tell an
american that they can have a four week
paid vacation at 90 percent of salary
every single year and all they have to
do is claim they have to take care of a
sick friend or family member you don't
think they're going to say that my
brother just got sick
you tell me everybody that had a
emotional support animal on an airplane
actually needed
peter you're ruthless you going out to
the animals no it's the people
no but people look people try to qualify
for these programs everyone's going to
want to take a month off every summer so
oh my god my my uncle needs my help my
kid needs my help i'm not feeling well
i'm depressed he just happens to live in
italy
[Laughter]
everybody's going to subtly have a sick
relative in the summer yeah all right so
when this happens uh
what is the impact the programs cost
more than they think and then they can't
get as much revenue as they think so
what is the impact in your opinion uh if
this gets passed and implemented well
it's just more inflation you know
because the fed has to print more money
that's why the fed is talking about
printing less money that's tapering but
they're gonna have to print more money
uh to fund these uh deficits otherwise
interest rates go way up and what
happens if interest rates go way up well
the deficits actually get bigger because
now the government has to spend even
more interest i mean even more to pay
the interest on the debt that it already
has not to mention the new debt that's
being incurred but also when interest
rates go up it hurts the bubble economy
because now everybody has to pay higher
interest so you can't spend more money
on other things because your your
interest rates went up your adjustable
rate mortgage went up
uh you know your credit card interest
rates went up uh people can
buy less stuff on credit because car
loans are more expensive so this whole
bubble economy starts to unravel and we
go towards recession or into recession
and when that happens government tax
receipts fall more spending on
unemployment so the deficits get even
bigger so the fed has no choice if it's
going to keep everything going
but to expand the qe program print even
more money create even more inflation
and and so the price increases that
we're experiencing now
you know are just a small taste of what
we see will we see 10 inflation in the
official cpi number in the united states
in the next three years you think i
think we will unless they rigged the
numbers again i mean i wouldn't put it
past them but assuming they leave the
cpi the way it is
probably we might see 10 next year is
inflation going to get worse in the
coming year well it has to get worse and
and in fact and again when you're
talking about price increases
you're measuring the consequence of
inflation the inflation is the expansion
of the money supply and we know money
supply is going to keep expanding
they're about to raise the debt ceiling
right so we can keep uh going deeper
into debt you know i always laugh
whenever they talk about it janet yellen
you know when she testified the other
day she said six times the government's
gonna be bankrupted but the
funny thing is she said we have to raise
the debt ceiling because it's important
that we pay our bills in full on time
well if we paid our bills in full on
time we'd have no debt right the reason
we have a debt is because we don't pay
our bills at all we borrow money so that
we don't have to pay our bills and what
janet yellen really means is that we
need to raise the debt ceiling because
we can't pay our bills we can't pay our
bills to take more on more we have to
take on more debt can i ask a serious
question and yeah i i'm scared to ask
you this because i'm going to give you
like all the ammunition in the world
if i
am taking money from one
investor or lender to pay back
the original yes lender ponzi well
there's two ways to look at it it's
called refinancing people doing
mortgages all the time right it's also
called a ponzi scheme if they're
investors that i'm not necessarily
refinancing yes i'm literally just
playing like a yes it is a ponzi scheme
that's why bernie madoff said that the
united states was running the world's
biggest ponzi scheme and that what he
did was nothing compared to that and i i
used that in his defense because no but
he just mentioned it like hey come on i
mean like he wasn't saying he said they
do it
but this was the thing did he really say
that was really his defense yes and then
the new york times wrote this piece and
they mentioned it and they said well you
know bernie madoff doesn't have any
credibility right so and i used to joke
and say wait a minute wait a minute he's
got credibility on one thing yeah
yes exactly that's why i used to joke we
should have made him secretary of the
treasury
the whole nature of what we were doing
you know that's pretty good
yeah and you know because but the thing
is the government janet yellen when she
tells everybody that if we don't raise
the debt ceiling we're going to default
that's an admission it's a ponzi scheme
right bernie madoff would never be dumb
enough to admit he was running a ponzi
scheme that's ponzi 101. you keep it
quiet right you don't tell everybody
it's a ponzi scheme because they're not
gonna okay
all right so that's the debt let's go to
social security because one of the
things that i'm very interested in wait
before you do that i wanted to i forgot
to finish answering the question as to
why the inflation is going to be worse
on a cpi
look at um producer prices okay producer
prices
2021
up more than consumer prices so
businesses were seeing their prices
costs rise
more than
what they passed on to their customers
now why was that it's because a lot of
businesses were reluctant to raise
prices they're worried about losing
sales to competitors and they were told
that it's all transitory okay we'll take
a hit for a few months it's transitory
we don't want to reprice everything and
then have to change the prices so
businesses kind of absorbed the rising
prices and and took a hit in their
margins
uh but i think by 2021 or 2022 rather
a lot of these businesses are going to
throw in the towel and they're going
gonna say you know what we gotta pass
this on
uh it's not temporary
and i think you're gonna see businesses
much more
willing to raise prices in 2022 than
they were in 2021
and is this where you see corporate
executives on their uh earnings calls
being like oh we raised prices and like
the customers liked it like it was
basically like that's basically what
people have said they've been like oh we
raised prices and the market accepted it
right they're not saying they liked it
they're just saying they accepted our
higher prices they tolerated it
uh and therefore now they feel
emboldened to do more of it because
they've seen like hey we did a little
bit we raised three or four percent
nobody left actually in some cases
demand is even higher and so if we raise
it five or six percent from here then if
nobody leaves we can just continue to
play this game yeah i mean they're going
to raise prices as much as they can i
mean in general businesses want to
maximize profits and so the reason you
don't keep raising prices is eventually
you lose sales but if all of your
competitors are facing the same cost
problems that you have
when you raise prices other people have
to raise prices too what ultimately
happens though
as you really start to raise prices
significantly it does impact demand
because not everybody can afford the
higher prices and then what happens is
businesses end up reducing capacity so
they can achieve their profitability at
a lower scale and then prices really
start to go up because now supply is
coming down because fewer businesses are
providing these products or services
uh and and you really get the spiral but
what's driving it all is the money it's
more money being created i mean they
keep talking about the supply side
problems i was you know just getting a
kick out of powell's testimony
because did you watch was that your
super bowl were you were you sitting
there and you you had a beer and like
some steak and
i didn't have refreshments or anything
but um but powell was like well because
somebody said to him well what did you
get wrong you know now that he's saying
it's not trans story and powell said
well you know
we got one thing wrong and that was this
supply problem the supply i mean and he
said but you know in fairness nobody
could have predicted this this was crazy
it came out of left field i mean nobody
could have realized that the effect of
the pandemic would have been like supply
chain bottlenecks and i'm like what is
this guy serious i mean
so
you basically shut down
the entire economy right all these
factories close
you furlough all the workers you
literally stop making stuff
and now you're surprised that there's a
shortage of stuff you're not making it
anymore how could there not be a supply
chain problem i pointed it out on my
podcast in march of 2020 as soon as this
happened i said i don't know why people
are talking about covet as being
deflationary this is inflation on
steroids because not only are we
flooding the world with money
we're stopping the production of goods i
mean we we're having less stuff and more
money to buy it this is like you know
double inflation uh so
inflation and
you know inflation is more money and
chasing less stuff well when factories
shut down they're not producing stuff
how do new variants play into this are
they going to keep this game going are
they going to keep doing it well i mean
i mean they're looking for excuses to
con continue these programs but the
point is
making the point that
when we shut the economy down right and
people stopped working they needed to
stop spending that was the right thing
to do hey you're no longer working
you're not producing goods and services
so you got to stop consuming because
you're not producing right so we but the
idiots in washington said hey we want to
make sure that these unemployed people
keep spending
on what we're not making anything but
they gave them all this money anyway so
that they could spend even though they
weren't productive so productivity fell
but they still had cash because they got
handed free money yes government they
went just a lot of that cash went into
assets though not consumed
well it went both places yeah because
some i mean in fact some of the people
that got stimulus money went right to
the robin hood and bought stocks some
people went and bought crypto with it uh
but look at the the trade deficits they
they skyrocketed all time record highs
we started buying all these goods that
people were still making in other
countries where they were still going to
work
but all of these things were very
predictable and it was a misguided
policy defended the opposite of what it
should have done we should have
contracted monetary support policy
supply along with the contraction of the
economy but we didn't want to do that we
didn't have the stomach for that and of
course we that the politicians could not
have ordered people to go home if they
didn't also say oh by the way we'll give
you the same money that you would have
earned if the politicians said hey you
gotta you can't go to work oh and by the
way you don't have any income people
would have said screw that i'm going to
work so did they have they had to do it
but it's bad because of the impact it
was horrible economic policy and the
obvious consequence
is this massive you know increase in
prices that we're seeing the supply
shortages but powell acted as if nobody
could have predicted this when it was
the most obvious thing that only an
idiot could have missed it and and the
question is if the fed is so you know
incompetent that they don't see that
when you stop production that you don't
have supply if they can't see that what
else are they missing you know what are
the other obvious massive problems
looming that the fed is clueless about
all right so when shift variant or some
other variant shows up
are they going to shut down the economy
or is that now too politically sensitive
and so they're going to basically do
everything they can not to shut it down
and they're going to use stimulus to try
to keep everything going like how do you
look at the future i don't know if
they're gonna try to shut everything
down again i do know that there are
a lot of you know factions that that
like to shut down i mean i'm surprised
the teachers union hasn't come out and
said oh oh uh omnicron we can't go to
school we gotta
send my paychecks uh you know i'm doing
homeschooling again or whatever
um where they did it online but a lot of
people don't like working in fact most
people don't like working they like
getting paid so if they can get paid
without working well that's what they
choose to do and they can use
coronavirus as the excuse